[truck horn blares]
- WELL, IT WAS A NIGHT
LIKE ANY OTHER,
EXCEPT I HAD JUST
TAKEN MUSHROOMS
FOR THE FIRST TIME,
AND I WAS TRIPPIN'
MY GODDAMN BALLS OFF.
OHH...
- COME IN, WALLY.
WHAT'S YOUR 20, GOOD BUDDY?
- YEAH, I'M TRAVELING DOWN
HIGHWAY 60.
I DON'T WANT TO SPEAK TOO SOON,
BUT I'M THINKING
I MADE IT OUT
OF GREMLIN TERRITORY.
- [snarls]
- [screams]
NO!
YOU SCARY LITTLE SON OF A BITCH.
AND AS I SAT THERE,
GAZING INTO
MY BEADY LITTLE EYES,
WHAT I REALIZED WAS THAT
I WAS ABOUT TO DISCOVER
THE MEANING OF LIFE.
MOONBEAMS.
LOOK AT THEM SILLY GUMDROPS.
- ALOHA, WALLY.
- GIVE PAPA A LITTLE PEEK.
- MMM, OH, WALLY.
- IT WAS SHAPING UP
TO BE QUITE THE NIGHT,
BUT THE NEXT THING I KNEW...
[police siren wailing]
OH, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO!
OH, GOD DANGIT!
OH, OH, OH, OH!
OH, MY GOD,
WHAT'S GOING ON?
GET OUT OF THE WAY!
WELL, MOVE YOUR WHEELCHAIR!
OH, MY GOD, A STROLLER.
NO!
[screaming]
OH, SON OF A BITCH.
- PERCENT OFF TODAY ON ALL--
OH, MY GOD!
[voice distorting]
[explosion booms]
[truck horn blares]
[emergency sirens wailing]
- AND THAT, MY FRIEND,
WAS THE LAST TIME
I EVER DID TRY MUSHROOMS.
I CAN'T SAY I REGRET IT THOUGH.
I MEAN, I BELIEVE
IT IS IMPORTANT
TO BROADEN YOUR HORIZONS.
HOW ELSE WOULD I HAVE LEARNED
TO LIVE AMONGST THE GRIZZLIES?
WOULD YOU PASS THE POTATOES,
DARLIN'?
- [roars]
- OH, BUT THAT'S A STORY
FOR ANOTHER NIGHT.
AU REVOIR, [bleep].